okay guys I'm just looking at the clock
and I'm conscious of the fact that yeah
one of the reasons why this is a hard
question because there's so much
information in there and yet there's
also so little you like I don't have any
links how am I supposed to work out any
of this we're not used to that very much
it's part of what I think makes it's a
very clever question it shows you when
you've got power in terms of
trigonometry how much you can do with
how little all you've got is these
bearings you don't know how far apart
these guys are you don't know how tall
the tower is you don't know any of that
you don't need to let me try and
illustrate how so general
problem-solving principle right when you
want to get toward something which is
uncertain you start with the things that
you know you start with the things that
arson and pretty much all we've got at
the moment is these angles these angles
of elevation right now importantly the
angles of elevation are not disconnected
they are all looking a B and C at the
same object the tower right and that's
why even though the question didn't ask
me to I've given the tower am i giving
it a name and I've given it sort of a
height here because then I can work with
this thing and connected to all these
other objects I called the bottom and
the tower T so I'm just gonna call the
top of the tower you staff medical okay
I saw a flash of thought there which is
great so here's what I'm gonna start
doing right
I want to connect these angles here and
this length along with stuff that's on
the ground right that's what I'm setting
out to do so I'm gonna start with one of
the right-angled triangles that's in the
diagram and by the way there are loads
right you might have noticed I didn't
draw this when you're paying attention
fashion try it out now you've got north
facing that way in red and east facing
this way in green so that's northern
that's East they're at right angles
aren't they it doesn't look like a right
angle but that's because we're in 3d
right
but this ATC is not the only right
angled triangle this flagpole because
nothing else has been told to me
otherwise I assume is vertical right so
every time it hits the ground
it meets at 90 degrees perpendicular
right so UT a 90 degrees UT be you
see all 90 degrees all right angles
right so I can say for instance in
triangle I mean what's start from a I
guess a B and save them we'll do them in
order in the Triangle which has an ax a
to you right I can use the fact that
it's right angle to connect this
flagpole to something on the ground I
mean I could work out this hypotenuse I
guess but the hypotenuse is all just
like floating in the air they're not
going to help me with bearings right
that's what I'm trying to get to so
instead of saying this a you this
hypotenuse which is floating in the air
what ratio connects my flagpole
a flagpole to this 80 the distance on
the ground which ratio might it help if
I drew triangle 80 you separately I've
noticed a few if you do this but not all
that many right if you're getting lost
in all the triangles separate them out
so you can see them on their own here's
the flagpole here's a the observer tease
the bottom of tower use the top this is
the thing I'm after this is the angle
I've got what's the ratio sarkar TOA
right think this is gonna be opposite
and this is adjacent
I want 10 right do you remember this
when we were looking at our own flight
pole outside just a flagpole this is a
tower isn't any way right we use 10
because you can connect a vertical to a
horizontal distance so I'm going to say
10 of 26 degrees what's it equal to H
over 80 thank you very much
opposite on hypotenuse the thing I
actually want is this distance along the
ground so I'm gonna write it like so
remember 1 over 10 I can just write a
shortcut and use cot instead of having
fractions flying around now because this
is a right angle triangle and I've got
the same right angle triangles 4b and 4c
I'm going to say similarly I can write
expressions for bTW that's from B along
the ground to the tower and CT from C
along the ground to the tower I can
write them they can don't look exactly
like this because the triangles are all
config
in the same way they're just slightly
different sizes so be T is going to be H
cot not 26 it's 28 thank you very much
and CT is going to be H cart 30 degrees
don't forget the degrees because we know
different units okay so now I've got
these three lengths on the ground I am
going to put these onto here there we go
so I've got H climb 26 going up this way
I've got H caught 28 sort of in the
middle of the day and on that way and
then lastly I've got Oh gross H cot 30
degrees facing this way okay so this is
helpful I don't know how toward this
tower is but I know how long these are
in relation to each other are you with
me so far
okay now what I want to get to from
these lengths is I'm trying to get to
this angle in here do you agree that
angle in there now in order to get there
this is a little bit tricky right I need
to think about this triangle that's on
the ground and this is not helping me
see that triangle on the ground this is
helping me see all the vertical parts of
this diagram but I've kind of dealt with
those now right I've gone from the tower
down to all of these ground measurements
so now I'm going to draw myself a new
diagram alongside this one this is the
second one that I mentioned to you
before even though in fact it's the
third one so I'm going to draw this from
a bird's eye view up north and over to
the east I've got a somewhere over here
see somewhere over here and then there's
their line of sight now some of you drew
this diagram first which is fine I'm
going to I'm absolutely going to use it
the problem is if you drew this first
you couldn't use your elevations because
this is all from the top right so
there's my angle to the tower all right
so I've got my H cot 30 my H cot 28 and
my H cot 26 and then there's a right
angle
well did I swap them around I'm sorry
it's the other way around 30 26 there we
go
and the one in the middle is just the
one middle okay now look with me right
I'm gonna put in blue because the only
thing I've got in blue here right what's
the angle I'm after this is the angle
here isn't it that's the actual berry
that's where I'm headed
okay so how can I use this information
that's on there right now to maybe start
to get towards there what's going to
tell you right off the face there's no
direct path to that angle but what might
be around that vicinity that we could
work out have a thing hmm
this is tricky isn't it just go back to
the top of the diagram right or the top
of working I should say we could make
all of these statements here we could
make all those statements because these
a TBT in CT they all say a right-angled
triangles remember that right I have
another writing would try and get a
different one and it has these two
lengths in it right
could I use those two lengths to work
out say this angle up here could I do it
how would I do it opposite and adjacent
in this a CT writer your triangle now
I'm going to ask you this question why
might I be interested in that orange
angle why might it be helpful to me all
right be careful right so I do have this
90 degrees here right but it's in the
big triangle do you see that if I got
this orange angle and then I could get
this angle I can start it did you what
do you want to change I said right I'm
going to repeat it is so important right
in this triangle here I've got this
length in this leg so I can use the sine
rule in this triangle the sine rule
needs two sides doesn't and I've got two
sides right so let's start to unpack
this where the black right here